hi my name is Adrian and I'm here to
talk to you about a brand new
open-source framework which my company
launched just two months ago called
streamlet and we've been in private beta
for about a year working with companies
like uber and stitch fix and IBM
research to develop streamlet and we
finally released it about two months ago
and it's been a kind of a wild ride
there's been like exponential growth and
there's a lot of activity on Twitter
that you can see about people building
cool stuff in streamlet and this is
actually the first time that we talked
about it sort of publicly so first of
all show of hands how many of you have
heard of streamlet cool all right have
you guys used stream button okay awesome
so well nice to meet you in person and
for the rest of you I'm happy to excited
to show you what we're gonna do here so
the outline for today's talk is or
today's demo really is this so I'm gonna
first tell you a little bit about sort
of the space in the Python data and
machine learning ecosystem that we see
streamlet filling and the problem that
we're trying to solve and then you guys
are all gonna be able to install it if
you want and play with it and then we're
gonna build a cool app and then I'm
gonna tell you a little bit about some
of the really deep motivating examples
for building streamlets use like I've
already used it and so some of the deep
motivating examples for using streamlet
and so to sort of motivate that I'll
tell you a little bit about my
background so I was a professor at
Carnegie Mellon University for eight
years and I did a whole lot of machine
learning and big data stuff and then I
went to Google X and I ran a machine
learning group they're working on
natural language systems then I went to
zukes
which is a four billion dollar
self-driving car company and again ran a
big machine learning group there and
then I saw at all of those companies the
same
kinds of problems sort of happening over
and over again and so that's why I
started streamlet with some friends in
2018 let me also say by the way that
given that my roots are in academia I
just strongly feel that it's way more
fun if people ask questions at any times
so please like raise your hand and ask a
question at any time it's just it's just
more fun for everyone including me any
questions ok all right
so what was this problem that I was
seeing over and over again and that
hopefully you guys might be sort of
aware of too and the the basically when
people typically talk about the
industrial machine learning workflow at
uber or something like that what they're
saying is that we have some data and
then we perform training on that data
and we build models and then eventually
we put those models in production and
it's all very complicated and we have to
build lots of software to support this
entire ecosystem and this is definitely
a very real difficult important part of
the machine learning sort of you know
pipeline and in fact there's a whole
crop of like amazing startups in this
space right now working on different
aspects of this pipeline and trying to
be a horizontal layer or take off
different vertical pieces and so I'm
actually really excited that like in a
couple of years this whole process is
going to look totally different and way
less bespoke than it does today but
notwithstanding this sort of major
production pipeline the thing that I
really saw as a machine learning
practitioner and I saw again and again
on teams is that machine learning
engineers are actually app makers that
is they often build a large number of
bespoke apps both to demonstrate data
like actually the previous session in
this room sort of demonstrated some some
simple panel apps to do that also to
sort of provide the interstitial
structure
for the machine learning group in in in
order to look at you know parse large
datasets coordinate with other members
of the team to see how models run on
different data sets there's internal
tooling to do that and then also to
project sort of the power of the machine
learning group out throughout the
organization so we're working with a big
company right now for example to allow
machine learning engineers to directly
build apps that empower a hundred
thousand sales people to make real-time
recommendations okay so these are the
kinds of apps that we saw again and
again being built by machine learning
engineers and really seeing that this
was actually a major pain point in the
process
okay why is this a pain first of all
before I get started do you guys do you
guys feel this have you guys been
building small apps and Jupiter
notebooks or perhaps with flask to to to
solve problems like those I described
maybe show of hands okay cool cool okay
did you build it in Jupiter okay flask
okay cool plotly - okay you've build it
in everything our studio shiny ok cool
cool so so what what typically happens
in this case so I'm gonna give you the
example of Zeus so we had about 80
machine learning engineers building
self-driving cars this is everything
from the planning system to vision
pedestrian detection the entire
self-driving stack basically and so an
example of a tool that we would have to
write would be something that would
allow us to take two simulations of the
self-driving car and run them at the
same time and compare them to one
another so typically this kind of tool
would start off as like a solo
programming project for a single
engineer so he or she is doing some work
maybe in a Jupiter notebook they are
actually running the simulations lo and
behold this is the typical engineering
you know cycle gosh I'm doing this over
and over again
I should automate this more and more so
maybe we copy and paste it into a script
check it into github now there's a way
of running this app and inevitably what
happens in this case is that if the tool
is important if a lot of people need to
use it all of a sudden it becomes a
central focus point for the group and
now we need to add new features every
single week and the app wasn't designed
to be like well designed app that you
can really add features to readily until
you get into this unmaintainable 'ti
trap okay so then what we would do at a
certain point if a tool was really used
by a lot of people on the team is we
would call the tools team and this is a
group of people who they were sort of an
internal infrastructure team for the
company and they were really sort of
subject Maddock matter experts in
building you know web apps and so they
were they had expertise in react or view
and and how you build the entire stack
and they would follow the sort of
standard app building flow which is to
collect requirements and lay out these
things and then wire them together with
the various events and so on then coated
up and you would get a very beautiful
app at this point usually very fast and
you know had all the correct features
and so on and so forth which was amazing
but then they'd say okay we just built
your app for your team we'll get back to
you in a couple months because we had
were supporting ten other teams okay so
what we got to was this sort of like
frozen zone where the the problem was
machine learning engineers either
couldn't edit these apps or I should say
really didn't want to or they did but it
was at great great it took it was really
time consuming so so that's really the
observation about the state of this sort
of really crucial workflow in the world
and so with that background I'm now
going to take you through first what is
streamlet and then we'll all get to play
with it a little bit okay any questions
or thoughts at this point
thumbs up alright cool
oh yeah you have a question oh no you're
just giving a thumbs up okay cool cool
cool yeah all right so what is streamlet
so streamlet is an app framework for
machine learning engineers and data
scientists specifically and the starting
point for streamlet was very different
from I think most app frameworks out
there we basically asked ourselves what
if we could make building these kinds of
internal tools and web apps that machine
learning engineers and data scientists
build as easy as writing Python scripts
so our fundamental assumption is that
you are a Python programmer and that you
are writing scripts in Python and that
you use this sort of traditional script
writing flow which is iterative
execution from top to bottom of course
that can be changed in a Jupiter
notebook that's okay too what you're not
doing necessarily is starting with a
layout and then trying to figure out an
event model right it's much more about
sort of a dataflow transformation model
in terms of how you build the apps and
what we wanted to do was build an
amazing app framework that really
started with this Python scripting idea
and so this is the app that I'm gonna
show you and we're gonna we're not gonna
build all of it but we'll build some of
it at the very end and what this is is a
it's actually a data browser for a
self-driving car image data and in fact
there's a little semantic search engine
up on the upper left there on the right
and you can select the number of sort of
various semantic features and images
like number of pedestrians and you can
scrub through them and then you can
actually run a network a neural network
in this case Yolo v3 just an example in
real time on this data set okay and this
entire app is
300 lines of Python and in fact there
are only thirty streamlet calls in the
entire app so the other 270 lines of
Python are actually the neural net and
all of the data processing so you can
imagine this is basically a data script
which has been slightly annotated to
make it an interactive app and that's
really the goal here okay questions
thoughts I'm gonna start asking myself
questions what's on the next slide
Adrian ok we are going to now if you're
interested install and play with stream
one so get out your laptops
actually before we get out your laptops
are you guys raise your hand if you're
able to install packages with pip on
your laptop ok cool
everyone sweet I'm at the right
conference alright so in that case get
out your laptops and get a terminal and
we are gonna do the following which is
pip install streamlet oh by the way this
is a open source project on github
Apache 2 license you can look through
all the source code so hopefully you'll
feel comfortable with pip install
streamlet I will do it myself
so here's my text editor here and I'm
just going to do pip install in my case
upgrade you don't have to do that okay
and so now you could run for example
streamlet version just to see that
things are not broken should be Oh dot
five one who has who has OH dot five one
okay
very few people okay okay
more go I need a way here raise your
hand if you want more time okay
yeah
the question is realistically when can
we buy autonomous cars I'll give you the
same answer I would have given you five
years ago
in three years I'll give you another
answer so this is this is unfortunately
not going to satisfy your desire to buy
a self-driving car for Christmas but it
was an answer I actually it turns out
that I was I was on the faculty at
Carnegie Mellon in the computer science
department robotics Institute and a
friend of mine was Chris Urmson who
ended up went on to lead the Google
self-driving car project now called
Weimer and I was like so tell me what's
going on with this self-driving car
thing and he said well it's really
simple what the car has to do is draw a
lot of boxes around things and then not
hit those boxes and it really just comes
down to like how many nines we have on
those two tasks and each nine is getting
harder and harder to get so okay who
needs more time you need more time I can
keep going
okay so pip install streamlet okay and
now a streamlet version o fi one so now
here's the fun thing to do
streamlet hello okay
and now what's gonna happen is it's
going to open a little web web server on
your computer and here we see streamlet
running and we have this little thing
doohickey here on the left that comes
out and these are a couple different
demos so I'll show you some cool demos
here so here's a here's an animation
demo fractals okay and and down here it
actually shows you the code that it took
to make this demo and interestingly it's
all the fractals I think there's only
like one or two little streamlet clouds
here so we have a little rerun button
and then I'm going to get to this in a
moment but you can change things about
the fractals so we could do that for
example and now this fractals are more
separate here's another example this
plotting demo so this basically just
shows like a random walk I'm using
Altair which is by the way I was super
rad graphing library made by some good
folks at Google based on Vega light
based on d3 and let's see here to do
mapping demo this one's fun by the way
I'm just gonna rap random sweet graphing
libraries doc GL by uber is so cool so
here we have next you gonna zoom out a
little bit so we can see everything at
the same time ok so here we have we can
turn on and off for different layers
really fast it's pretty cool and again
this is this is the code right here and
this is basically most of this code is
just Dec to yell ok so there's almost no
stream line to do this and that's kind
of I hope you get it sort of the theme
that I'm getting at here which is that
I'm gonna hopefully give you guys like a
cool superpower that you can use in your
work and in your own workflow I should
also by the way mention that this is not
only free and open source but it runs
entirely locally on your machine so for
example this is just running on my
laptop which there's no like data
leaking out or anything like that
we do collect analytics but you can turn
that off that's so that our investors
give us more money but but there's no we
don't we don't know anything about what
you're doing and in fact if you could
turn off the internet which I won't do
now it says the gods at the demo will
get mad at me you could turn off your
internet and this would all just
continue working perfectly there's no
there's no cloud thing
on here cool in fact you'll see that
this is actually a localhost 8501 yeah
why is Bato 3 a dependency remind me at
BOTS or 3 days again oh yes yes yes
that's a great question yeah so if you
so ok if you install if you set a
setting actually this is really we
should probably get rid of that
dependency if you set a setting in your
config to mol file you can actually save
your streamlet reports to to a cloud
server and in fact the way that that we
configure that is on an s3 bucket for a
for a corporate customer actually so for
example at uber we set it up so that
they could save stream it reports to an
internal s3 bucket that they had and
boto 3 is actually a reflection of that
but it actually it I could actually pick
uninstall but a3 and everything should
still work again I'm not going to do it
now because I don't upset the demo gods
but yeah
oh yeah yeah okay yeah and by the way I
should that's a great question I'm gonna
repeat the questions too so the first
question was or the last question anyway
was moto3 why do we why do we use that a
dependency and indeed it's because there
is a functionality which is off by
default that lets you upload your
streamlet apps to a s3 server okay and
the second question was what charting
libraries do we support and actually the
shout-out here is to Jupiter because we
basically get to Jupiter means that
there's tons of awesome Python bindings
for all kinds of awesome things and we
essentially can plug them into streamlet
practically for free so I suggest that
you go to the docs which are right here
extremely Daioh slash Doc's but and
there's it shows you everything but doc
GL plotly matplotlib boquete holo views
altair vega light i can probably think
of all a tech yeah yeah yeah the
question is can you handle events yeah
I'm going to show you how to do
interactive stuff yeah cool
uh-huh yeah so the question is is this
is there anything at all for more than a
shiny app so so the well we see this
playing a similar role in the PI cup
Python ecosystem that SHINee does in the
our ecosystem as you'll see there's a
very different sort of programming style
to streamlet so when we get into that
you can you can see whether you like it
or not cool okay
yeah
right so the question is how do you
deploy a stream lit up so right now we
don't offer we don't offer a solution to
that you can go online and you can find
like probably one or two dozen tutorials
about streamlet on ec2 and AWI ec2 and
Heroku and all these things and so
there's actually a fair amount of
information there's a growing body of
information written by the community on
how to deploy stream live apps in fact
we are also developing a deployment
solution called stream it for teams and
that's going to be the enterprise
version of streamlet yeah so that's how
that's how we will eventually make money
although we're not making money now
right yeah so the question is what about
is your what about GCP or other cloud
providers so right now you'll find
tutorials written by the community
online for every major cloud provider
and also things like docker containers
and so on and so forth so it is a little
bit of a involved process right now and
so I apologize for that but if you're if
you're sort of fluent in those
technologies you can get it done and we
encourage people to sort of you know
write write more tutorials if you'd like
to if you come up with a better way of
doing it
so we also hope to make that a really
amazing experience for our users but
that will come down the line yeah yeah
can you back to the cluster okay I'm
gonna have to keep moving after this
question but thank you for asking
questions yes you can well so for one
thing streamlet just is pure Python so
streamlet run it basically just says run
this script well you'll see what
streamlet run if you haven't gotten
there it's it's it's it's the same thing
as Python but it means run it as an app
rather than as a script so in that sense
the entire Python ecosystem is instantly
available to streamlet so any kind of
thing that you could import in your
environment spark whatever it is is
available to you as a streamlet app
developer then there's another question
about how do you deploy to clusters
which is something that you can read
tutorials about and also something that
I can talk about after the talk but I
think I should keep moving because we
got a there's a lot more cool stuff I
hope to show you anymore quite well no
no more questions
no more questions for another minute or
two okay so that's streamlet hello so
let's see here
okay I did anyone have any trouble
installing cool yeah two people yes
Oh watchdog okay are you in Conda you're
not in Conda what what operating system
are you on okay okay okay
watchdog is like the bane of our
existence basically it turns out that it
requires it needs to be built because it
uses some operating system resources and
we might just push some like upstream
changes to it
but it doesn't always compile properly
my suggestion is to build streamlet in a
virtual length or in Conda and and it
should work so I apologize for that
yeah there is also a way of disabling
watchdog which I am forgetting at the
moment so I will think about that that
yeah and get back to you okay let's get
moving so cool all right so now this was
to your question about shining let's
talk about what is the how does this
work so our goal was we really wanted to
make someone who is comfortable writing
Python scripts sort of immediately have
the superpower of being a Python app
developer how do we do that
streamlet works on three simple
principles if you understand those
principles you understand all of stream
level number one embrace Python
scripting so streamlet apps are actually
just scripts that run from top to bottom
so if you can write everything that you
can do in a Python script factor things
into functions write it in your favorite
IDE whatever it all works perfectly in
streamlet so this is a little hello
world will write this in a second and
there it is executing as an app okay
number two
create widgets as variables so here in
my script you see that I've inserted
this streamlet function called st dot
slider and anytime you have a variable
anywhere in your scripts that you'd like
to make interactive you can just
substitute SG slider or any kind of
widget that you want and it sort of
automatically assembles the UI so that
that's now a something that can be
changed interactively okay
and finally reuse data and computation
so I'm gonna talk about this thing
called St cache but what that allows us
to do is actually play this trick of
rerunning script over and over again
without it being insanely slow by
caching computation okay so that's the
basic of streamlet and so now to
actually play around with this who got
streamlet installed on their computer
raise your hand oh sweet yes high
numbers okay I'm gonna ask you guys to
go to a github repo and just copy a
little bit of code so go to github.com
slash stream button I'll do it myself
good over here
there it is github.com slash streamlet
here we are probably way too small for
you to see and then we're gonna go to
demo uber NYC pickups really the only
reason why we're doing this part is
because there's like a little snippet of
code to download the data that's super
annoying to write and I would not want
to describe it to you like character by
character so we're gonna go here here is
yours here we are and then we're gonna
click on app dot PI and now what I'm
gonna do is gonna zoom in a little bit
let's grab everything from line 47 up
oops we don't need the whole license we
can start an import streamlet SST
I'm gonna move this what's up
47 oh sorry
18 247 yeah really really we just want
38 to 44 to be honest that's the kind of
gnarly part but you just grabbed this
whole thing no we also need to get the
bucket mm-hmm okay so I'm gonna copy
this and I'm gonna go over to my text
editor here oops I already pasted it in
and here we have lines 1 through now
that now it's 1 through 29 so raise your
hand if you are at this point okay cool
we had like a 90 percent drop in so the
point is I have these first 29 lines in
a text editor
basically like this is in vs code I have
yes code on the left
I know so we have a different model than
the reactive computation that you'll see
in Chinese so you'll see it's not very
complicated and we're about to get to it
actually so yeah so yeah the question
was what's the what's the relationship
between caching and reactive computation
there are some deep connections but we
won't go to too much into that now but I
think you'll see when by demonstration
that how it works okay are you guys all
here so raise your hand if you need a
little more time okay so what I'm gonna
do now is I'm this is this guy I'm
calling it hello dot PI you could call
it anything you want I'm gonna here we
are on my my little text editor here I'm
gonna say streamlet run hello dot PI
okay so what's going on here so a couple
of things first of all we have this
little title thing at the top so these
are these you know there's actually very
few function calls instrument so it's
pretty easy to learn
but you know we have s T title or
another way that we could do that it was
we could just say s to you right oh and
now when I save my file this is a little
trick that we're just borrowing from
like web development it's actually going
to scan the file and it's going to say
we saw a change in your file do you want
to update what you're seeing on the
right so I'm gonna say yes I do want to
do that
always rerun okay and now you see that
uber pickups in New York City got
smaller and this is actually marked down
so we can just make it big again or we
can make it a little bit smaller
oops the other thing that we could do by
the way if you're in Python 3 is you can
anytime streamlet sees a Python object
which is not a function call it it wraps
it in st dot right so we could also just
go like this
which okay sell it's kinda nice we could
also get rid of this markdown yes okay
I'm just showing some random stuff you
don't need to follow along with this
I'll tell you in to follow along again
okay cool
and we could add some wise okay cool I'm
actually gonna delete this because who
cares so now here's where things are
interesting we're gonna load a little
bit of data from from the web and then
we're gonna do some non-trivial
computation like well this is not like
mind-blowing computation that we'll get
at you a PhD but it actually takes a
little bit of time which is what I mean
by non-trivial so first of all we're
gonna load a hundred thousand lines of
this data
these are Buber pickups in New York City
it's the fun little data set you can get
online and we are going to rename the
columns and we are going to convert one
of the columns as a string to a date
time and believe it or not well you
probably you guys know this it's like to
you a very time-consuming thing to do
it's like a high entropy code path to
turn a string into a date time so okay
and now we can take a look at the data
so I'm just gonna say data and I'm gonna
tell a streamlet to display it okay and
and here we're looking at these pickups
so what do we have here these are this
is the date time of the pickup and then
this is the latitude and this is the
longitude and this is something called a
base that we have no idea what that is
but it's always the same thing and
typically and a script like this would
actually be slow to rerun cuz we have to
go to the web download all this data do
all these transformations so why is it
not slow in this case it's because of
this s/t cache annotation actually we
don't need this either this you can keep
it if you want I'm going to delete it so
here it is running and then what this
annotation does is basically say store
this data and then every time I see this
function call again if I already know
the answer just substitute
back in so four major computer science
nerds this is just memorization but it
in this case it means that we can now
play with this data set like basically
interactively even in the context of
this script so for example I can add we
can look at only the uber pickups at
noon so I'll say hour equals noon and
then we'll do a little filter date/time
DT okay and now we're looking at only
the uber pickups at noon
and if I change this to 11 this is sort
of the beginning of the streamlet magic
it updates instantly okay is anyone
following along at this point in terms
of actually coding yes there's a
question right there
okay you're you're seeing a blank page
my guess try okay this is what I would
do I'm gonna just get rid of everything
here except for this dream let pretend
it's not there and we're just gonna say
SG dot right hello world
oops oh what's going on here oh here we
go I would just try these two lines of
code and and if that doesn't work then
then we'll have to think more deeply yes
yeah oh sorry yeah so I I was speaking
very quickly so the question is like
what's this thing about wrapping stuff
in st dot right first of all you can
just not do that
and it just uses st dot right ordinarily
and it'll everything will work I there's
actually a slightly more complicated
description of what gets automatically
st written it's a sort of naked object
sitting in your buffer that's not a
function call it's not a comment it's
not a if statement or a while statement
or other kind of syntactic construct so
you know like for example I could say
true and it'll say true but if I said if
true it won't say anything because if
true doesn't fall into the special
category of things but if I say if true
42 then it'll do that last question for
now yeah
okay so I okay so the question is it's
really about what is this st cash thing
doing and what happens I think what
you're asking is what happens if you
mutate the object that comes out of st
cash is that the question huh yeah yes
there it should it's a it's an important
constraint that always the same number
the same thing will happen every time
your script runs if you don't change
anything so I I would be surprised if
that weren't the case but but but that's
certainly the mental model and I could I
could look at your code and see what's
going on but just give you in a sense
here if I say data and then Len data so
I have thirty three thousand nine
hundred if I change it to 11:00 a.m. I
have three thousand nine seventy seven
if I change it back it goes back so that
should always be the same
okay is your question answered okay call
we get yes good your hello world worked
yeah okay so I I think it's gonna be
impossible for everyone to follow along
perfectly with the code the whole time
but if you can please do and if not I
think the you can gestalt what's going
on any other questions
cool all right so we're where we are now
is that we have this ability to quickly
filter through this data just by
changing one variable here so there's
10:00 a.m. 11:00 a.m. okay let's do
something more fun which is actually map
the data so let's just let's get this a
raw data okay you don't have to do
exactly what I'm doing here and do it
this okay so this is the raw data at
11:00 a.m. now let's actually map it so
we'll put something here and we'll say
geo data and now I'm going to use a new
visualization function which is st dot
map okay now we're actually looking at
where these pickups are happening right
and this is by the way using deck GL and
so this is pretty cool so now we're
going to get to how would you play with
interaction and so the first thing to
note is that basically all I've shown
you right now is how to write scripts
that output something to a web browser
like super quickly and hopefully not
without too much difficulty but this is
not what you would call an app yet okay
but on the other hand it is very much in
the style of an ordinary Python script
we load some data we transform it and so
on okay so now we're going to make it
into an actual app so as I mentioned
let's let's resubstitute this variable
for a for a widget so it's called this
hour
and here we go min value max value okay
so 0:24 which I think it's 23 there we
go okay I'm gonna zoom out a little bit
so you can see this better okay
and now you'll see that as I change the
snoopin a little bit here as I change
this everything updates right and in
fact you'll like for example it's not
like rebuilding the web page from
scratch every time in fact it's very
intelligently diffing what was in the
web page with respect to the data that
your app has and then sending only the
deltas that are required to make that
possible that's one of the reasons why
it's so fast and and so ok had I not
known how st slider works just I'm just
randomly riffing here we could actually
just take a look at st slider and here
is the documentation for it just a fun
little trick another fun little trick is
like well you know this kind of annoying
how this thing is is right there
maybe I can move it to the left so
instead of saying SG slider there's
another area you have access to which is
called the sidebar st da sidebar that
slider and now we've got a nice little
sidebar there and zoom out cool right
and now this map it's a little boring it
so happens that Dec GL is like super
amazing and like insanely customizable
rather than actually type in all kinds
of crazy deck GL I'm just going to copy
it from github because it looks cooler
that way we're just gonna replace that
one line with about maybe 15 lines of
code okay and now we have a really cool
3d visualization of all these different
things right and and by the way you know
if we didn't like a slider we could make
this a can we what could we make this oh
I think we have something called an enum
input now this is actually cool
No
well you guys a slider for now I can't
remember what it's called if someone if
someone's yeah good what's that what's
that oh I typed number oh cool oh there
we go
cool so now we have the same thing but
with a different kind of widget for
example and then here to like you know
maybe you know we we don't we don't
always want to look at these this is
more for like a debugging thing so I'm
going to show you another cool thing we
could do we could say we're going to use
a different type of construct if STD
check box show raw data okay so now the
data is kind of hidden back there see
that so notice that we're not writing
any callbacks we're not doing any kind
of declaratively we're really just
instrumenting a script with these esti
calls and what they're doing is they're
allowing us to control the control flow
at the same time as insert UI elements
which produce this script that you can
play with and and share with others in
case anyone's wondering whether you can
run streamlet in a Jupiter hub instance
the answer many people have asked this
and the answer has been no until about
five minutes ago when mathematical
Michael comm just demonstrated that it
is possible and I have no idea what kind
of magic was involved in doing that but
that's super awesome so so maybe
hopefully you'll share that with the
community cool alright good hopefully
everyone's feeling a little stretched
out so let's build a data app okay
so in this final segment I wanted to
share with you a little bit about sort
of a more advanced use case for
streamlet so the even though the
fundamental building blocks are
themselves extremely easy hopefully if
not you should let us know because we're
constantly trying to make them easier
I'm not kidding but even though they're
hopefully not you know super
sophisticated there's not a huge amount
to learn about streamlet you can
actually build really non-trivial apps
quite quickly and so I'm gonna tell you
a little bit about one of the really
driving use cases behind the creation of
stream lab which was my experience at
zooks working on self-driving cars and
so what we did was all of the I was an
engineering manager there and all of the
engineering managers would meet once a
week and we would basically look at
instances where the car hadn't behaved
as we expected and so this was the
operator of the self-driving car but it
pushed a button or whatever that
figuratively speaking that caused the
car to disengage okay and then that was
an issue that had to be resolved that
week basically and so in a sense this
workflow was similar to the software
engineering workflow where you have
issues coming in and then you need to go
into github or whatever JIRA and then
you they get assigned to people and then
they get fixed but in this amorphous
crazy world of semi-intelligent vehicles
and machine learning it wasn't that
simple right
you couldn't root cause a neural network
right so what was the actual flavor of
like debugging a self-driving car so
what it really was was the engineering
leaders sitting around a table and we
would sort of open up this is this is
way moe just copied off the web by the
way but same idea we would open up an
instance it's a little hard to see there
but in this case what we have is it
looks like a someone in a wheelchair
following a dog around on the street and
this is the kind of thing and this is
actually quite an exotic example but
this is the kind of thing that happens
all the time
you're debunking self-driving cars is
that like every single week no matter
how many years you've been working at
this some crazy thing happens that
you've never seen before and you're like
how is the car gonna behave in this case
so that's perhaps another answer to the
question why this is taking so long
there's tons of weird examples about
this maps are like that too by the way
every time you think you've made a map
that's like centimeter accurate some
crazy thing happens in the world and
your your map is broken ok so what we'd
do is we'd say let's figure out at this
point this is a very complicated to see
this is not just the people in the room
there's like project managers and
project managers and stuff there's this
entire sort of ecosystem working on this
problem people are trying to say at this
point in time can we understand what all
the sensors were doing what we must
state all the neural nets were et cetera
et cetera the planner and then can we
get it in some sense to an engineer or
an engineering team who can sort of
break it down further and try to like
quote-unquote reproduce this case but
because there's no such thing as
reproduction as such the I mean you
could you can replicate the state of
everything on on the vehicle but that
that's only one instance in time what
you're trying to get as a more general
understanding of what broke down okay
what you really want to do is you
actually want to create essentially
searches over your data set for similar
instances in time and then what you want
to be able to do is essentially regress
those searches over your data sets
against different versions of the
software running on the car so yeah the
picture here is that we have this data
which is vast it's you know terabytes or
exabytes god-knows-what of data and we
want to find subsets of it that are
similar to this error case and then on
in the other column we have quote
unquote column or let's say dimension we
have all the models I can quote unquote
models because really there's like many
many models running simultaneously on
the vehicle but again we're gonna sort
of sidestep that and just think
theoretically so we have data along one
dimension we have models along another
direction and we want to be
but a quickly subset some of these and
then look at the intersection how would
the models run on this data that's sort
of the beginning of the process of
debugging some kind of crazy thing
that's happening on a self-driving car
and and by the way this is you know when
I was at Google acts I wasn't working on
the self-driving car team but I was
close to them and I'd this is the exact
same process in every project that's
working on self-driving cars no doubt
and so what happened was the engineering
teams eventually through this
complicated slow process built internal
tooling that made this better and better
and week after week more features were
added until we actually had these really
beautiful tools that allowed us to
interrogate our own data and then rod
run models against it and this kind of
internal tooling is being replicated not
only in L of every self-driving car
project but also really in every machine
learning project on some level and
especially once you get to a certain
size team so this is an example of sort
of the hidden bespoke internal tooling
layer that floats beneath the the
amazing mathematics and and futuristic
technologies of machine learning and so
we built an example of this tool in
streamlet now it's a very small
simplified example but it gives you some
idea of how of how this works and so I
will invite you to go check out this out
on github I'm not going to invite you to
run it because it's going to download a
three gigabyte neural network maybe
maybe it's five hundred megabytes I can
remember uh well I'll tell you right now
bring up my bring out my thing will
close the streamlet browser
oops why did I interrupt him oh just
control see you can't interrupt yours
okay
well I'll help you with that afterwards
yeah you by the way you can also open
another terminal and kill it if if all
else fails okay okay there's 200
megabytes
point is if I tell you guys to do this
right now all the same time you're all
going to simultaneously download
children events and that would probably
just kill the Wi-Fi and make it horrible
for everyone so I don't take
responsibility for the PI data la Wi-Fi
system so I already have it downloaded
and then afterwards you should feel free
to do what I'm about to do try it at
home or pride at your hotel room so here
we're gonna go to let's go back to the
streamlet github by the way this is
streamlet itself and as i mentioned it
is an open source project we're actually
getting a whole bunch of contributions
from the community not a huge number
we've been in public for about two
months but I think we've gotten like 15
or so pull requests which is like super
exciting and then there's also lots of
other stuff on the forums and Twitter
and all that stuff as you can check out
but and you know Apache too and you can
you can play with all this stuff and
look through it more importantly but
what we're going to do is we're gonna go
to this demo self-driving thing and here
is another it's just another little
example of streamlet and I could
download this file but we have a cool
little feature which is that you could
just run a Python script directly off
any URL so really all this it is running
locally on my computer just downloading
it first and then it's running that so
it's just a little time saver so we're
gonna run this baby boom okay alright
and so here we are in the app and I'm
gonna go down here to show the source
code
honestly the point is that this is the
entire source code it's 300 lines and if
you look carefully
okay let's actually go into this
source code and zoom in you'll see that
like literally this is everything that
you're seeing including actually running
the neural net somewhere around here
layer by layer okay the whole thing is
happening and we're not like hiding
things in other libraries or something
so this is the source code again it's
300 lines of Python only 30 streamlet
calls okay and so there are some
extremely calls right there okay and so
let's let's run this and see what
happens so here we go to run the app
okay
just doing some SD cache stuff load
metadata by the way is building this
little search engine over the data set
this is the Udacity self-driving car
data set so it's just a nice data set of
images with boxes around them basically
and so here we are here we can start to
say let's say that the situation was I
you know we we ran into a situation
where there was there were a large
number of traffic lights let's say so
let's go to here and we'll say traffic
lights and then we'll go for a large
number of traffic lights and then here
we just only six images in the data set
with over fourteen traffic lights of
course who's ever heard of over fourteen
traffic lights but here we can scrub
through it let's go for pedestrians you
know what actually let's make this like
way bigger because it's more fun we can
get into more normal levels okay so so
there we got like a lot of pedestrians
now and here we can scrub through it and
notice all of this is written without
callbacks and the same exact sort of
data flow style that I described to you
earlier it's just a script that's run
from top to bottom but it gives you this
really convincing illusion of an app you
might say and then notably down here
it's actually running a neural net in
real time so and just to prove that here
we can we can we can change parameters
of the neural net itself so you'll see
that as I increase the confidence
threshold more and more people get
classified
as people and then as I decrease it you
know fewer and fewer and then similarly
there's this thing called the overlap
threshold so these are actually these
are actually parameters of the net
itself so this net is pre-trained at
which it's not parameters of the net its
parameters of the post-processing that
happens after the neural net is run so
all these objects are detected using
Yolo which is a super-awesome object
detection by the way and and then you do
so little post-processing to figure out
what's the overlap threshold and stuff
of boxes and and these are the kinds of
like you know I don't need to tell you
of millions and millions of tiny little
parameters there and inside the neural
net system and which are extremely
difficult to debug and really gain
intuition about at all and so you can
imagine that we would have not only this
one model but perhaps thousands of
versioned models that we could then run
against this data set and so this is an
example of an app that like on the one
hand it's not very complicated it seems
almost like formulaic perhaps just grab
some data grab a model run one against
the other but on the other hand there's
a lot of very minor bespoke things about
it and so the ability of for a machine
learning engineer or data scientist to
build this him or herself directly open
it up and fiddle with it and then make
it available to other people inside the
organization to their co-workers to
their executives to their interns and
batad potentially far beyond the machine
learning group was really what we were
trying to go for when we created
streamlet and hopefully it's something
that that you guys are also resonating
with as both part of your workflow and
also a skill that that that could be
useful to you so quickly yeah
yeah yeah so so there's basically the
the it was more of a statement than a
question which is that this would be
really useful to sort of serve a model
not in the sense of let's say an API
endpoint which is not the point but
actually as a data app as it were with
inference yeah and that is that is very
much one of the use cases that we had in
mind so that so that's exactly right
I would also encourage you guys to go to
your interested go to Twitter and type
in the streamlet you'll find that people
have put up like thousands of different
apps you can also search on github for
streamlet and there's a lot of
interesting things that people are doing
now so there's there's those kinds of
like deploy a wrap and inference of some
kind there's people who are just
demonstrating really cool like
demonstrating their github repos we're
seeing that more and more like oh if you
want to see how this thing works just
pip install streamlet and you can use
you know blah-dee-blah
and then there's annotation tasks there
is just a whole bunch of weird science
stuff going on in streamlet which is
really delightful and it makes it super
fun to go to work okay another question
huh yes yes yes okay so the question was
could we could we just render this down
to an HTML document remove the back end
yes so that's a great question yes and
that's what the botto library is for so
you can if you go to streamlet dot io /
docs we describe so this has only been
out for two months and we're going to
make it cooler and cooler and cooler
right now there's some things derp a
little bit you have to just do it
yourself in this case if you go to the
config file you can configure it so that
you can save HTML files out and you can
save it to s3 buckets and that's what
Bato is for so yes so you cannot save it
outside of s3 buckets now because that's
the only use case that we coded that
being said it's an open source project
and that's a very great use case and
it's not a big delta from what we have
now it's it's in fact actually that part
of the whole program is a plug-in system
so you could have like the file system
save or you could have a DCP save we
just only wrote one plugin for it so far
so there's a lot of things like that in
streamlet where it's like we have really
big plans and we'd love to engage the
community and helping us like build out
all these things and also gain ideas for
how to build things I instantly mention
that almost every good idea in streamlet
was just came up with people who were
using it especially during this
year-long beta period so there's a
really long private beta period where we
just got tons of ideas from the
community so now that things are growing
we're trying to sort of scale up that
same process but - too many more users
okay a question in the back yeah yeah
so the question is is it expensive to
run inference with neural nets and so
the answer is yes the I let's see we
actually have a really cool game demo
that you should check out or you can
like more faces and stuff and that's a
really fun streamlet application and we
haven't put the source code up just as
we haven't had time to but that I think
will probably do it like the next month
or so so you can play with Gans and
streamlet and it's super fun
number two training neural nets is much
more expensive than running inference on
them so actually deploying an app which
runs inference like at the speed of
someone clicking is like orders and
orders of magnitude less computationally
expensive than actually trading a neural
net at the speed of a GPU and so in that
sense it probably has something to be
concerned about in most applications I
will mention that people have been
starting to train neural nets in
streamlet and using treatment as a
front-end to that process sort of as
like a bit of a almost like a tensor
board alternative which is not sort of
main use case for us but another cool
idea yeah that's right that's right so
the key thing here is that we do not
nothing here is running on any cloud
server as in the demo that I just showed
you it's just running localhost 8501 so
the only cloud server that's being
connected is one which is actually
measuring a very little anonymized
information like was an app created or
was it an app basically interacted with
and we use that because that helps us
understand it and also demonstrate to
our investors that people are interested
in using streamlet so we you can turn it
off but we would prefer that you leave
it on yes
is it possible to upload data oh do you
mean you want to upload data in the UI
yes that is a feature that should be
coming out next week which is the file
uploader widget and in fact if you want
a proof of this go to github and search
the issues for file uploader widget and
I think it's all been merged in so it
should be coming out node 5 - yes yeah
so so the Enterprise version is called
stream it for teams and there are two
versions and we're not sure which one we
are going to come out we're developing
it right now or not sure which one we're
gonna come out with yet the first one is
an on-prem version that's something that
we have running like on our servers in
in our organization and then there's
also a cloud version for for like
smaller typically smaller organizations
who don't like have a huge on-prem
installation so that's something that
we're developing right now it's we're
doing it with a small number of partners
who are existing extremely users but you
can actually go online to streamlet
thought is slashed for teams and type in
your email address if you wanna get
added to the waiting list and people
will contact you and say how big is your
organization and stuff and so we're
certainly looking for it to gain insight
into how people might use the deployed
version that that's that's not available
yet so it's coming on yeah
mm-hmm
that's a very okay that's a very
sophisticated and fascinating question
which is how could what's the next part
of the of the workflow for a machine
learning engineer who's doing debugging
in the sort of self-driving car use case
and is there a way of maybe maybe
plugging it into a regression suite or
something so that's not a problem that
we don't consider that a part of the
streamlet problem definition as such
we've used streamlet as an app
development framework for others to
canvas for others to create apps in we
chose Python as the launch language for
sort of infinite reasons but one of them
is that there is a very large ecosystem
of plug-ins for you know basically every
other SAS service out there so the
limits really your imagination and and
certainly if you come up with cool
integrations with other services feel
free to put them on the web too as
separate open-source projects or you can
do pull requests against streamlet and
and the ecosystem can hopefully get
richer with that way okay we're just at
the end of the talk here so oh we are at
the end of the talk here so thank you so
much for your time and attention and I'm
available to chat with people afterwards
but thank you so much
[Applause]